much and as Congress considers national
police reforms local police chiefs are
also under pressure to make changes and
that includes Minneapolis chief Metiria
Aaron Dondo he says his department is
withdrawing from a contract or rather
from contract negotiations with the
police union which he views as an
obstacle to reform and his comments came
the very same day that Thomas Lane one
of four former officers involved in
George Floyd's death posted bond and
left jail Jeff Pegues is in Minneapolis
for us where he spoke with the chief
Jeff good morning to you good morning
Tony
I know it doesn't look like it but this
is a police precinct it looks like a
fortress this morning look at all these
barricades stacked up one on top of the
other and it's razor wire surrounding
the building since George Floyd's death
this Police Department has it's image
has really taken a hit and that is why
the police chief here is under a lot of
pressure to make big changes as city
officials way dismantling the
Minneapolis Police Department chief and
area arredondo confronts the actions of
the four former officers once under his
command how did it feel for you to see
those four cops who report to you not
listen when the crowd was saying hey
ease up you have community that are
literally crying out for you to help mr.
Floyd it was gut-wrenching for me in a
very emotional for me as a chief under
pressure to respond the chief is backing
out of negotiations with the police
union which he sees as the roadblock to
disciplining bad cops arredondo took
command of the department in 2017 with a
reputation for being a change agent
George Floyd's death in custody has
raised questions about whether there
have indeed been reforms did resigning
cross your mind over the last two weeks
at all not at all history is being
written now and I need to make sure that
we are part of the right side of history
arredondo has the backing of Minneapolis
Mayor Jacob fry both believe police
reforms not disbanding the department
entirely are the right path
and while reforms began to take shape
sources tell CBS News that investigators
are looking into whether George Floyd
and Derrick Chauvin knew each other and
if so what the relationship was in a
recent interview with CBS News David
penny who worked at the same club said
he knew both men is there any doubt in
your mind that Derrick shavon knew
George Floyd no he knew and that they
bumped heads how well did he know him I
say pretty well now he's suddenly
backtracking saying that he made a
mistake in an email to CBS News penny
says he had confused Floyd with another
unnamed african-american coworker
writing I did know Derrick and he did
have those run-ins with my coworker it
wasn't George this comes days after an
almost hour-long interview in which
penny described in detail
several alleged interactions between
Floyd and Chauvin but penny did not back
down from his comments about Chauvin
calling him aggressive with some patrons
the nightclubs former owner Maya
santamaria do you think Derrick had a
problem with black people
I think he was afraid and intimidated by
black yeah
it is really a mystery this morning how
penny could have mistaken Floyd for
someone else Floyd was 64 and over 200
pounds the reality is a lot of people in
this community right now they are
reluctant to talk about the club or
George Floyd or Derek Chauvin with the
ongoing investigation meanwhile in this
city the police union says that the city
could be breaking the law if it breaks
off negotiations gale no right you have
some surprising news in your story and
that shot of the police precinct very
jarring thank you very